famines have a range of causes from
droughts floods crop failure locust mass
displacement due to war government
policies and increasingly financial
speculation and global warming but what
exactly takes a nation from food
insecurity to famine according to the UN
a famine is when at least 20% of
households face extreme food shortages
and there is acute malnutrition in over
30% of the population and when there are
two deaths per day for every 10,000
people over the past three decades
famines have claimed the lives of over a
million people in the Horn of Africa
particularly Ethiopia Somalia Sudan and
South Sudan so how will the
international community respond to the
next man
you